When running the new programs on the Atelier Robin, the light can be very dim and it can be hard to hear any noise.
Is this normal?
Yes it is.
So if I have updated your programs and you have an Atelier Robin,
I have put, I have rewrote literally every single program of all the 1500 other programs I literally rewrote.
And I wrote them if it's appropriate in what's called the 11th harmonic.
And when you're running the 11th harmonic, you're really running two frequencies at the same time.
The primary treatment frequency and the 11th harmonic of that treatment frequency.
And because you're running two frequencies, it really cancels out the noise and the light will appear much dimmer, especially if you have our new bulb.
So the new bulb carries more gas.
And the benefit of it, you're going to get more treatment from it.
And the other benefit is it's not going to be nearly as bright because it's crystallized as well.
So it's crystallized, it's running 11th harmonic and it's more gas in the bulb.
So it's going to be a much dimmer bulb.
Matter of fact, I tell people, we've had people call it, this is, I don't think this is working, turn off your lights.
Oh, now I see it.
It's really hard to see at all in the daytime.
And the noise, especially if you're used to running a program that's not on the 11th harmonic of the lower frequencies, it's going to be much louder.
But now running with the 11th harmonic, some of the higher frequencies you can't even hear the running.
So yeah, it's just beware of that.